The day before Thanksgiving,
we went to my nana's house,
my dad's mom's house.
And you know, I'm not gonna get
too sad, but I will say that
it was difficult in one way particular
because it was the first
time Papa wasn't there.
You know, having passed away months ago
and with my uncle Dan also
passing away right before that,
which I've talked about on the show.
So it was like, there
was this anticipation of,
"Okay, there's gonna be some
empty seats, so to speak."
Now, it was never a plan
to leave seats empty,
but actually what happened,
what had happened was after our concert,
I've told you this, right?
Well, at our concert at the
North Carolina State Fair,
my mom and Louis road there
with my dad and Nancy.
So this is your parents
and their new partners
hanging out together?
Yeah.
And nana all rode in dad's truck up there
because they were concerned about parking.
But it has been 30 years or more than that
since your parents were a couple.
So we've had a lot of time
for the awkwardness to
settle a little bit.
Well, they have never ridden
in the same car anywhere.
And so when dad and Nancy
offered to take them, I was like,
"Okay, I'll let them know."
And then like, they did
it and it went great.
And then come to find
out on the ride there,
the ride back there talking
about Thanksgiving plans
and how we're coming into
town for Thanksgiving,
now it's Christmas time.
And they were like, "You know what?"
Dad and Nancy were like,
"Sue, you and Louis should
come to our Thanksgiving."
And I'm hearing about this and I'm like,
"After they had decided?"
They were like, "Well, we were invited."
I was like, "Sounds weird but great."
Okay.
♪ We make the rules ♪
So, but to the first time ever,
my mom came to my dad's side
to like a big family event
on my dad's side of the family.
But I will say, 'cause if-
Even birthday parties growing up,
I mean, they were all separate.
I'd have twice as many birthday parties,
twice as many Christmases.
What I'm getting at is.
You know, this is, you know,
super common in modern society
for families to split up
and there'd be two entities.
And then the children have
to kind of make choices
and go from place to place.
It is pretty novel concept.
If you can all get along
I mean, get together.
It sounds like a movie
because it's probably is.
Christmas Eve we'd always
go to nanny's house.
My mom's mom, my dad's side family
and had him nothing to do with it
because Christmas night was nana's night
for my dad's side of the family.
My mom had nothing to do with that.
I was the only one that would do both.
And it was great.
'Cause I got, you know,
you end up getting a lot
more presence, I think.
Well, yeah, definitely.
But now I don't really get much presence
and this is Thanksgiving.
So presents are out of the equation.
Oh, your family doesn't
do Thanksgiving present?
No, they don't.
We're not even thankful.
Oh.
Just kidding.
We don't even do thankful.
It was this interesting dynamic.
And there's like, I
mean, I think there were
what was the number?
Ended up being like 16 people there.
So it wasn't like an awkwardly
small group of people
sitting around a small table.
It's still a very, we're putting
a bunch of tables together.
It turned out to be, you
know, there were still moments
of it being very sad.
You know, it's like really experiencing,
missing these key members of
our family for the first time.
So it in no way erases that,
but it created something new.
I mean, my cousin Kurt,
and they had a newborn,
you know, three months old,
first time we met the baby,
it was like, so there's all
this excitement that like,
gives something to celebrate, you know,
which was very much needed.
And then I looked down
at that end of the table
and it was like, my mom's sitting there.
It's like so weird but this is great.
I mean, I think everybody's
having a good time
and you know, everybody
did have a good time.
It all worked out.
And at one point, you know,
I've talked about Louis,
my stepdad, who I'll never call my stepdad
because of that's just weird.
'Cause they got married
way after I got married,
but I'm like his catch
phrase,:Good, good, good."
Told you about that, right?
Yes.
We talked about it, we built it up,
but the kids were like,
"All right, Papa Louis
is gonna be at the
Thanksgiving dinner tonight."
And they're like, "Tonight?"
And nana's like, "Yes." So-
Let's do a drinking game kids.
Every time he's just, "Good, good, good,
you take a shot of gravy."
That's a good idea.
And yeah, I'm like, "Silly
you've got to listen for it."
And then lo and behold, the
kids get up from the table
after like we're all
sitting there at the table
after the food, after everybody's eaten,
some people start getting
up there doing stuff,
but most of the people still at the table.
And then Louis is like,
"Oh boy, that was good."
My ears perk up.
And I look across the
table at Christy's like-
Pulling a cord.
Christy's eyes met mine.
And he was like, "Oh gosh, that
was good. Good, good, good."
I was like, "Yes."
And then Christy and
I looked at each other
and that was like the best
moment of Thanksgiving.
And then I look around for the kids
and they're not at a table.
They didn't even witness it.
I think Lily was at the table
and she didn't hear it somehow.
And that was the only, good,
good, good of the whole-
You're kidding?
That's the only one he did.
And he gave you like a warning shot.
Yeah.
I mean, everybody could have
gathered around during that-
I got it, I just wanted
the kids to get it.
I mean the next day, which
was Thanksgiving day,
we're at nanny's house.
So my mom's side of the family,
my dad and Nancy weren't invited to that.
I don't know, it didn't go both ways.
I don't know what happened.
Interesting.
And were there,
Louis didn't give a
good, good, good there.
It was good, good, good.
Did he have a bad, bad, bad Thanksgiving?
Well, it was great,
Thanksgiving was great there.
It was like nanny and her
siblings, uncle Jimmy was there.
Never seen uncle Jimmy.
Yeah.
He was there.
He's hard to understand.
I love the way he talks.
It's just the, I'm just saying.
It needs to be subtitled?
Yeah it needs to be.
He needs to have his own
subtitle around his neck.
He needs to have an iPad that
he wears that has subtitles.
I'm not gonna do an impersonation
because I think that would
be cruel, but it's it...
I love him for it.
That's the thing about getting
together with your family
is just, yeah, I'm in
more observation mode,
you know, it's not like
we're getting into deep
conversations or anything.
We're just sitting around.
Nanny gets so cold that
she set that literally,
it was like 85 degrees.
So tropical.
And so like after we've
eaten and it's 85 degrees
and you're sitting shoulder-to-shoulder
in this like carpeted living room
with like the kerosene heater on,
like everybody just started wilting man.
And then a couple of family
members would have to go outside
to smoke and then they come back in
and like, me and Christy
are really sensitive
to the smell of smoke.
And like, we got headaches
from just the residual smell
on the clothes.
And we started to really
have a difficult time.
So we had to, I was like,
Well, mom and Louis had to
go to Louis' family's thing.
And then we were gonna
stay like two more hours.
I'm like after another
hour and the dog shows over
and stuff, I'm like-
The dog show?
We were wilting, we had
to like get out of there.
So I'm like, well, and we had seen nanny
another day before, so we
got some good quality time.
And then I was like, we said
our goodbyes and headed out.
And then we get out to the
car and Christy is like,
"Well, we can't go back to Brittany's
because they're not there,
they're at JBs family's house.
And we don't have a key
so that we don't have somewhere to be
for like two and a half hours."
I'm like, "Well, I really need a coffee."
And it's Thanksgiving day
and we're driving around to "McDonald's"
and then I get into "McDonald's"
and I'm like, "Yes."
And then the door at
"McDonald's" is closed.
And I look across I mean,
and then I'll look across the street
and they got like a gas.
I can't get gas station coffee.
So then we drive to Fuchs Way I'm like,
there's a "McDonald's" in Fuchs Way.
There's a Starbucks in Fuchs Way.
I go to both of those,
they're both closed.
I'm getting desperate.
I go to the 'Dunkin' Donuts" closed.
I'm starting to feel
like a real loser now.
I'm driving my family
around on Thanksgiving day.
Just feening for coffee
and getting turned away like "Les Mis."
Well, okay that's a little...
Okay.
I don't remember this story "Les Mis."
I didn't watch the movie.
It's exactly like that.
Christy's like, there's a Sheetz.
I'm like, "Gas station coffee?"
Sheetz is not a gas station.
Well, you know what?
You know what? I have
never been in a Sheetz.
I've never been inside of one.
What?
I've heard about them.
You can order food from the gas park.
You can order lattes from a
screen inside, which I did.
Of course you did.
And that explains why on Christmas day,
me and my immediate
family were playing cards
for an hour and a half
in a Sheetz gas station
because we had nowhere to be.
That's why I got a group
text of you playing cards
in a gas station on Thanksgiving.
And you know, I felt kind of defeated.
I'm like, "Is this a father fail?"
Does this answer the question
at the top of the show that
like, it's better to not be
with family on Thanksgiving?
'Cause here I am choosing to
play cards just with my kids
and my wife in a Sheetz gas station.
And then Christy's like, "You know what?
This could be a tradition."
Oh gosh.
And it's a magical phrase.
No matter what happens,
if it's bad, try this.
Next time you're in like a weird defeated
or odd holiday situation just
don't even think about it.
Just say it out loud.
Speaking into the ether.
This could be a tradition.
Everything changed at that moment.
Like I got a tingle on my spine.
A Sheetz tingle.
I got a Sheetz tingle.
I'm like, "Yeah, even if we're
not here for Thanksgiving,
we can fly all the way
here to go to this Sheetz."
And it's like, "No, we didn't mean that."
But it changed the perspective
on the whole thing.
A sponsorship from
Sheetz would definitely-
Work it.
Change it.
So that was my Thanksgiving.
And by the way, then I left there
and we met Britton and his
family at a Waffle House.
So I went from a Sheetz
and then spent the next
two and a half hours
at a Waffle House on Thanksgiving nights.
That's an upgrade.
Both places are great, but
Waffle House, that's prime.
We walked into the Waffle House
and the manager looked at
us and he said out loud,
basically at the top of his voice,
"What the hell?"
And I thought it was like,
"Yeah, Thanksgiving night,
I know we're here at a Waffle House
course so are you manager?
It's great that you're here
so that I can be here."
And then it turned out
at the end he was a fan,
but he didn't tell me that until
two and a half hours later.
So yeah, gas station in a Waffle House
on Thanksgiving night,
it can be a tradition.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.